thank you
[Music]
what up guys welcome back to another
episode of a off the Record and today we
have a very special edition one so we
all know that Ryan is a musical genius
that's right that's hyping it up way
hard so that's what he said to say we're
gonna do Story Time with Ryan where we
share some of our most personal stories
and Ryan will score to them and we've we
figured a very very good heartfelt
sentimental story to start off with was
one of the worst ass beatings I ever had
as a kid from my dad
oh wow all right
so I got my tickets on Amazon this is
when um I was in second grade
I was going to a private school across
the street from my public school because
I already got expelled from the public
school and
um I had this special skill where I was
really really good at uh losing jackets
lost jackets every week Tupperware never
could come back with my stuff and I
think after repeated times my parents
got pretty fed up like where the [ __ ] is
that jacket I bought you I think it was
50 bucks where's the Tupperware did you
even eat the food that I made you and
um I just never had an answer for it so
this time my dad picked me up or my
parents already divorced
he uh picked me up from the private
school and he's like where's your stuff
so we have like this checklist and I
opened my backpack no Tupperware and
then he goes where's your jacket no
jacket
and so he goes come over here I'm like
okay
he takes me into the bathroom next to
the church and he starts [ __ ] wailing
on him
and I was screaming my brains out
because I was [ __ ] seven years old
and I'm like
and then the school secretary came in
and shut the door she said what's going
on in here and I'm like help me Mrs
Mason
[Music]
threw me into his blue uh Mazda truck
and we drove home when we drove home uh
he opened the door and he threw me
inside and he locked the door and so the
only place that I knew at that house
that I knew that I was safe because all
doors have locks right and then they
have keys I can open except for the
master bedroom bathroom is the kind that
could only be locked from the inside so
I ran in there I locked the door and I
just hear my dad was like really scary
I was like holy [ __ ] I was so scared and
it was it didn't make any sense but when
you're six or seven you get so scared
being in there that you're like [ __ ]
I'll come out so you open the door when
I open the door he starts kicking me uh
smacking punching me all over the room
uh through the hallway living all that
and then we go into the backyard
and uh on the side door there's a fence
and there's like a straight away and I
started speeding up I think I was
running so fast
and after my dad picked up a baseball
bat
[Laughter]
[Music]
enough
bruise on my leg but I was so scared
that I couldn't stop so I just kept
running and I knew that the door
so I knew I had a split second to as
soon as it swings back I have to make
one of those moves as my dad comes out
he's like what the [ __ ] video
so as soon as I ran through that door
all night you got to be smart about this
if I continue to run far which is what
my dad thinks he's gonna track me down
but you know how they have they say like
keep your friends close by enemies
closer I was like if I hide at home he's
never gonna think I'm even at home so I
I ran out and I immediately made a quick
left and here's this little wall
separating our house the driveway to my
neighbors and there's a bush right here
so I went right around the bush and I uh
I I hid behind the bush so my dad just
like how I thought he would be gets in
his [ __ ] blue monster truck bones out
into the street
[Music]
uh come back around and go just back and
forth kind of like uh kind of like a
shark in the ocean
[Music]
yeah it's back in front back and forth
and then I think finally he gave up and
um that's when I went home and I didn't
know what to do because I really felt my
life was in danger so I called my mom
and I I told her everything and this was
the uh it wasn't like God was
disciplining me it was almost like I
felt like Dad was gonna kill me so uh we
ended up my mom had to file a
restraining order until there's a period
of time when my dad couldn't see me
because how bad he beat my ass and to
even go through the whole core process
how to take all these like pictures over
like butt naked and stuff to show all
the bruising all over the body
and that was the worst ass beating I
ever got
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was a treat
[Laughter]
roses in here who gives a [ __ ]
you'll [ __ ] the news right it is from
now on oh dude
it's short and sweet to kind of it's a
midge it was sweet though it was sweet
definitely the ending was the best part
when they took pictures of Bart's
bruises
[Laughter]
that is [ __ ] crazy dude but the music
helped the time that you couldn't see
him
I think it was like at least a few years
wow yeah damn yeah how soon after was
the Ethan Allen incident
oh that was like maybe
maybe four or five years later when
you're helping your dad buy a house
recently
do you um do you go into the master
bedroom and in the bathroom and go oh
look Dad it's uh only one-way lock
wouldn't that be coming handy someday
damn
oh no it's crazy though because like my
dad will see me even just like be Stern
with taika and he's like don't you talk
to him
I'm like bro you [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
out of me he was trying to make up for
it dude I've swung the baseball bat we
had an old wooden one he just picked
them just but because I think I'm just
getting away yeah so I think there's a
time where it goes from like he thought
I was gonna wrap around your ankles
it goes from one to a cartoon
disciplining the kid to like I need to
win this ego battle you know well
luckily it was really light-hearted when
taking me out to the ball game started
playing huh it could have been a lot of
child abuse but I was feeling really
happy that that honestly the soundtrack
made that like child abuse case sound
like way better way better than by the
way you guys don't know what you're
missing out on because we were just
spitballing like hey Ryan play this over
the break and dudes like [ __ ] can
play anything that he listens to
it's ridiculous it's easy enough oh
please but everything's easy to hit no
it's time literally everything's easy
we're like come on dude most easy for
you yeah that's not gonna happen anyways
dude yeah he did he did YMCA like happy
he did one different ways he did it
happy sad like triumphant yeah like like
a little a little cheerful yeah you know
a little understated he did that [ __ ]
song me and Anthony were singing
yesterday what's what's that one which
one
oh oh oh the other one yeah Andre
Bocelli oh the one that will uh Will
Ferrell does it's stepbrother so yeah
Time to Say Goodbye basically goodbye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh this is when the the Angels win the
pennant and then that doesn't come
anyway
and then it cuts to the bar where the
dad's just [ __ ] drunk and [ __ ] like
that in the bar one more time
and then but then they play YMCA and the
dad's like oh yeah
the spirits are back up
okay well great job
awesome Legend thanks for sharing